we begin in pakistan where an explosion
has killed at least
10 people including children that blast
happened at a religious school
in the city of peshawar at least 70
others were also injured
well our correspondent kamal haider is
watching all those developments for us
from the capital islamabad
come on just tell us what happened here
well uh first of all it's important to
understand that this particular attack
took place
just on the outer fringes of peshawar
city which is the provincial capital on
ring road
uh the explosion taking place inside a
mosque
which also acts as a religious school at
the time
there were quran lessons that were
underway according
to preliminary investigations a a person
carrying a bag full of explosives walked
in
a time device we are told now with five
to six kilos of explosives
and that bomb going off during the
lessons
we're also told that the number of
wounded is now over a hundred
most of them are under treatment and
hospitals in peshawar
particularly the lady reading hospital
and there are fear that the dead toll
could rise because some of these
uh students who were there are badly
wounded
well kamal of course this area also
isn't a stranger to attacks can you talk
us through some of the context here
yes in fact what has happened uh for the
past few years
the terri ke taliban pakistan which has
been out
outlawed by pakistan was operating from
pakistan's tribal areas in 2014
the army pushed them across the border
into afghanistan
and they have been involved in deadly
attacks that also includes
dice so there would be suspicions that
perhaps the daesh or the islamic state
which is
also rearing its head in the tribal
regions
along the afghan border are have also
taken responsibility for some of these
attacks so
it will be interesting to see whether
the terrible taliban pakistan was
involved in this attack it should also
be remembered that
it was in 2014 when a deadly attack took
place on army public school
in which 130 students were massacred so
it'll be important to see but the
suspicions of course would be
that it is a group that has been
outlawed perhaps a splinter group of the
cherry
taliban pakistan or perhaps the islamic
state itself
shall a very volatile situation there
kamal haider for us watching
developments from islamabad thanks kamal